no [ __ ] way dude if he won that fight
it would have been a horrible travesty
of justice how do you remember Alessio
Sakara versus Tallis latest no I don't
you know remember that one know what
happened that one
Saqqara got the decision but Silas Lake
just took him down over and over never
really got hit standing and took his
back like two or three times really and
sakara escaped all the back attempts and
then got back to his feet so the replays
were also Cara's escapes back escapes
what was it guess who won it's a car
yeah really
because the replays influenced the
judges man you think so I know so did I
was in the truck doing that oh wow
what did you say hey how come you guys
aren't showing the replays of the
takedowns in the back control I don't
remember what happened
where was that watch that fight I mean
you'll see at the end all the replays
are Saqqara escaping back control and he
won was this back in the day when was
this this was probably about 12 years
ago oh well yeah they don't no they
don't the [ __ ] there is gonna throwing
chicken bones to decide watch that fight
and then tell me who won I don't know
wow it's amazing that you brought that
up that's a crazy fight maybe never
forget that one that's how I know that
sticks in my brain like those replays
that's that's why I bottle that's like
replay because the judges are sitting
there going oh my god what do i do what
do I do
so they look at the replays and if the
replays are showing one guy is getting
the better the other guy then they go
okay um if they in the truck they think
he's winning so then okay he's winning
you know what's crazy is that that's
what happens nothing nothing really
significant is changed in terms of like
the the who judges fights it's like
basically the same kind of people the
same people you don't you're not seeing
look you
Ricardo Almeida's a judge in New York
which is a great thing but you're not
seeing a lot of that nothing you're not
seeing a lot more of regard Almeda type
do yes yes either form of fighters or
martial arts experts like if you say you
want to be a judge I want to see you
show me how you applied arts chokes show
me what's different scene anaconda choke
in the dark chokes show me
you know show me how how do you do a ten
finger guillotine show me show me if you
don't know what that is you don't know
how to do it how you gonna know whether
or not someone's in danger whether in
the middle of a fight I'd also show him
fights like the one you were talking
about with Sekar and ladies and how do
you score this right we're talking all
sorts of [ __ ] common sense dude
Dominick Cruz well I don't want to say
that but he says so [ __ ] hot part of
what he said I will not repeat yeah he
says [ __ ] hot you can't say [ __ ]
that's you know I can say that I can't
say what do you show you you want smooth
yes